[Music]  there were dragons when I was a boy  where they went  only a few know our story changed the  world forever we did it the world's  first dragons Viking utopia Julia don't  be on maybe Mike's lace Claire did it  more Oh Santa honey hey wait up oh he's  not the only one she's a life fury oh  sorry did he just disappear  Wow  it's a hidden dragon worth  toothless go introduce yourself has a  girlfriend I've hunted every Night Fury  except yours and him over I will never  give him up then I won't destroy  everything you love  we are no longer safe here we all have  to disappear completely off the map we  have to fight for their freedom  [Applause]  [Music]  you don't nothing without your dragon  [Music]  show them what you got but  [Music]  save him  if you and me buddy always  [Music]  [Music]